buongiorno
il tema che affrontiamo oggi a quello
del riuso degli spazi e si può
affrontarlo in questo modo descrivendo
la situazione c'è il contesto in cui
siamo oggi come casa bossi non è un
contesto isolato una necessità della
della repubblica italiana è uno dei
tanti beni culturali che il nostro paese
lascia vuoti non ci sono soltanto beni
culturali sono un po questi le
descrizioni del vuoto fabbri fabbriche
dismesse che appaiono industriali
dismessi sono 700.000 ex scuole
abbandonate chiuse asili e poi spazi
comunali chiusi i lasciti serie di
quartiere spazi civici macelli foro
boario colonie solari i beni
ecclesiastici non usati i paesi fantasma
cioè quelli agglomerati di case che
vediamo quando guardiamo la campagna o o
la montagna
l'anas con tutti i suoi caselli le
stazioni ferroviarie i luoghi del
divertimento abbandonati i centri
commerciali che cominciano a chiudere
negozi vuoti sono 650 mila quindi in
totale queste tipologie abbiamo un
milione e mezzo di spazi vuoti
ok un milione e mezzo di spazi no che
non hanno più una funzione d'uso o che
hanno una vocazione indecisa che qui
rappresentano un problema che il censis
definisce come un capitale in agito che
il nostro paese di fatto a disposizione
e che riesce soltanto in minima parte a
riusare l'approccio che possiamo seguire
cercare di pensare a un problema come
una risorsa e
cercare di capire come mai siamo
arrivati a questa situazione
problematica cioè come mai di fatto no
nel nostro paese il che è un paese
basato sul mattone il valore del mattone
comincia a perdere a perdere
l'importanza e se noi perdiamo un
singolo un singolo bene cosa vediamo che
negli anni con l'andare del tempo c'è
stato una svalutazione da degrado perché
ci sono dei rischi atmosferici anche no
cose banali che negli altri anni non
c'erano non si erano mai verificati ci
sono rischi nuovi poi c'è un aumento
della tassazione sugli immobili anche
questa non si era mai verificata nel
nostro paese in questi in queste formule
poi ci sono tutte quelle svalutazioni
che possono arrivare da fenomeni di
vandalismo
no anche negli spazi vuoti abbandonati
possono succedere per cui con il passare
del tempo
bene perde di valore e arriva un punto
rispetto al quale se non si interviene
con un'operazione di riuso si va in
quella situazione del non ritorno
c'è di colpo pensate un capannone crolla
il tetto e cominciare un valere
no non dico più nulla ma proprio poco
per cui un'operazione riuso anche
temporaneo anche un'apertura minima
permette al bene di tenere il di
conservare il valore oppure se si fanno
un'operazione ancora più importante no
di aumentare il valore
pensate al al fatto della della
situazione in cui siamo dove per un
attimo sospendiamo di parlare degli
spazi mettiamoci un altro fenomeno
quello della disoccupazione giovanile
non siamo mai arrivati nel nostro paese
ad avere questi livelli di
disoccupazione giovanile
siamo arrivati nel 2014 a un 44 per
cento
guardiamo la politica come in questo in
questi anni di crescita della
disoccupazione giovanile ha guardato le
giovani generazioni ho segnato dieci
anni di frasi eclatanti che ci
ricordiamo i bamboccioni di padoa
schioppa sfigati fuoricorso i precari
che erano stati definiti da da brunetta
l'italia peggiore
i mammoni della cancellieri i chiusi
della fornero senza ambizioni di elkann
e poi le ultime due sono del ministro
poletti
rispetto ai giovani all'estero aveva
detto alcuni è meglio non avere tra i
piedi e poi aveva anche detto per
trovare lavoro è meglio giocare a
calcetto che mandare un curriculum
ok quindi noi abbiamo un milione e mezzo
di spazi vuoti e una situazione di
disoccupazione giovanile è così che non
si era mai verificata e le istituzioni
molto distanti da questo tema proviamo a
mettere a me care le due cose e vediamo
un pochettino facciamo un'ipotesi
economica se noi su un milione e mezzo
di spazi vuoti neri usassimo anche una
minima parte dall 1 e mezzo al 3 per
cento che facessimo queste ipotesi che
vediamo qui siamo a casa bossi facciamo
uno spazio qua dentro e trovassero la
possibilità di creare un nuovo lavoro
due persone in ognuno di questi spazi
il contributo di questa leva di questa
manovra alla riduzione della
disoccupazione giovanile nazionale
andrebbe dal 48 al 10 per cento
e questa un'ipotesi economica
allora io non sono non sono certo un
economista no vedo queste cose che però
accadono e ho scritto al sole24ore
dicendo io non sono un economista però
vedo queste cose
queste cose succedono no in tantissimi
luoghi dell'italia sono circa 5.000 gli
spazi che sono stati riusati del nel
nostro paese e quindi ho detto se è vera
questa cosa qua ma dite voi servirà
queste ipotesi allora possiamo scrivere
il libro e da qui è nato questo libro
riusiamo in italia che di fatto è stato
presentato in più di 100 occasioni 101
102 occasioni davvero in tutta in tutta
italia si è partito da corleone poi
taranto e poi siamo venuti surin in
italia cosa succede che in queste in
queste situazioni nascono forme di
attività che non sono più beni pubblici
no perché non è il bene soltanto
completa del pubblico non sono neanche
però beni privati o di proprietà del
terzo settore no pensate gli enti
ecclesiastici piuttosto che le
associazioni ma sono quelli che si
chiamano formule ibride definiti oggi
beni comuni allora bene comune cosa vuol
dire che io di questo bene da una
funzione comune ma un po come siamo qui
adesso
ok
e quindi abbiamo una nuova categoria di
beni che si fa con la gente comune e
quindi più importante l'uso la fruizione
che se ne fa del bene della proprietà
stessa del bene questi progetti di
rigenerazione di riuso hanno tutti
queste caratteristiche
allora quali sono le le difficoltà per
riuscire a operare su questa scala sono
queste quattro per passare a spazio
vuoto è riempito di idee e talenti
passione e lavoro bisogna imbattersi in
queste quattro dimensioni la
progettazione allora bisogna avere
competenze legate alla progettazione che
vuol dire di fatto saper scrivere
progetti formula riguardare europea la
fondazione bancaria agli enti pubblici
ma anche un sol crowd funding quindi non
usare anche tutte le tecnologie 2.0
quindi avere questa capacità qua di
tradurre un'idea in un progetto poi
bisogna occuparsi del tema della
sostenibilità sostenibilità economica e
finanziaria
questi di qua o sono sostenibili o non
si può pensare che la cultura continui
ad essere sostenute dall'ente pubblico i
ragazzi che si occupano di rigenerazione
del ragazze e ragazzi ci dicono questo
che nel settore culturale per lavorarci
non è detto che bisogna aspettare
l'ennesimo concorso pubblico per
operatore culturale del comune ma si può
davvero iniziare a fare si usa molto la
parola start up ma non è stat up inteso
di impresa definita dalla legge monti
start up e dire iniziare a fare qualcosa
un lavoro queste ragazze dimostrano che
si può anche inventarla un lavoro che dà
reddito che da busta paga
bisogna occuparsi del tema della
sostenibilità e poi c'è il tema della
governance e preghiamo di beni comuni di
spazi comuni ci sono tante persone
coinvolte tante associazioni ma chi è
che poi decide allora anche qui bisogna
fare regole chiare fin dall'inizio se
non è un pasticcio ultima prima
questione è proprio la realizzazione
pratica c'è il passaggio dalla
progettazione alla realizzazione
necessita di imbarcarsi in questi
aspetti tecnici e burocratici riuscire a
superare tutti questi aspetti tecnici e
burocratici sappiamo che non è facile
sappiamo che in italia per
prendere uno spazio vuoto aprire un bar
e far suonare fare musica quindi una
cosa più normale sono necessari 11
permessi rilasciati da undici enti
diversi sburocratizzare potrebbero
aiutarci in questa direzione quindi ecco
il quarto tema da affrontare
e questo vediamo un pochettino qualche
buona pratica no questi sono sono
questioni che vanno affrontate con una
capacità forte di essere visionari qui è
proprio necessaria la creatività
creatività che non vuol dire
un'invenzione no di qualcosa che non c'e
la prima vuol dire saper guardare a un
problema anche esiste una situazione
nota in modo diverso e quindi ecco
perché qui siamo a favara no una
galleria d'arte residenza per artisti e
in provincia di agrigento che prima non
c'era parte dalla visione di due privati
che dicono questo questo paese in cui
c'era stato un crollo era morta anche
una bambina però è anche da una tragedia
non può essere invece un'occasione di
rinascita culturale per un paesino
dimenticato e nasce questa roba qua da
turismo questa cosa quindi da lavoro poi
questa cascina cuccagna
anche qui siamo a milano poi c'è chi
dopo racconterà magari da qualche cosa
ma questa è una cosa eccezionale parte
dal basso
proprio come dire queste operazioni qua
non è che sempre devono vedere come
primo protagonista l'ente pubblico
l'ente pubblico gioca un'altra parte qui
e dal basso che le persone si dicono che
facciamo
c'è una cascina vuota è l'ultima cascina
nella cintura di milano proviamo a darci
una mano e un po alla volta la regione
riamo che cosa può fare ciascuno di noi
da questo punto di vista
qui stiamo a novara tutti quanti possono
contribuire a mappare il vuoto
magari non il vuoto
quello che non sappiamo che destinazione
potrà avere tra quanto potrà essere
disponibile ma quello quel tipo di vuoto
che immediatamente disponibili che è
usabile domani quello che può essere
messo a disposizione per quelle quelle
persone poi il continuo dire ragazze
ragazza meno questione generale
generazionale per quelle persone che
hanno voglia di impegnarsi a riempire
quello spazio di idee e di talento di
lavoro
allora se facessimo delle piattaforme no
in città che misurano quali sono gli
spazi disponibili perchè sono di
proprietà pubblica oppure anche di
proprietà privata finiti fuori mercato
ma che di fronte al fatto che ci
potrebbero essere un gruppo di ragazze e
ragazzi che hanno voglia di rimettere a
posto un proprietario lo può dare
no in uso in concessione gratuita o
giusto il rimborso delle spese
ecco un impatto del genere potrebbe
generare una una situazione che
permetterebbe la creazione di un lavoro
diverso un lavoro appassionante un
lavoro emozionante un lavoro rispetto al
quale si sviluppa anche un tipo di
rapporto affettivo io vedo queste
persone che lavora in questi spazi a
queste persone piace proprio andare a
lavorare non contano le ore di lavoro
che fanno lì dentro perché hanno la
possibilità di realizzare il proprio
talento
ripeto partendo da spazi vuoti se nelle
città riuscissimo a fare queste mappe
cui tutti quanti computer si muovono
potremmo contribuire e il costo
dell'operazione sarebbe bassissima
l'impatto no in termini culturali
sociali e relazionali
no ma anche poi lavorativi sarebbe molto
elevato sarebbe uno di quelle manovre
che di fatto costerebbe pochissimo e
avrebbe un risultato enorme quale invito
che possiamo fare tutti quanti usare uno
slogan che
meno mattoni e più neuroni cioè mettiamo
in circolo idee e occupiamoci di questa
manovra che potrebbe davvero a
contribuire da una parte a ridurre la
disoccupazione nel nostro paese ma
soprattutto a renderlo migliore
grazie dell'attenzione
[Applauso]